Philip now Lord Hammond was the
chancellor of the exchequer under
Theresa May between 2016 and 2019 and he
joins us now good morning thanks very
much for being with us
um just before we get to the budget I'm
quite interested to hear your views on
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank How
concerned should we be well look it's
not going to affect many individuals in
the UK because not many people bank with
Silicon Valley Bank but it is going to
affect the very important fintech sector
in our economy where there's a huge
concentration around Silicon Valley Bank
UK and there's a lot of small early
stage businesses that are quite
important to this economy quite
important to keeping our financial
services sector at The Cutting Edge who
will be very very nervous today so I
hope that in the course of the day the
government the bank of England
Rothschilds who are managing this
process can come up with a solution that
allows those businesses to get access to
their funds tomorrow morning and
reassure their customers their investors
because this is a very important Dynamic
sector and we don't want to see it
suffer a massive own goal here and those
plans have been worked up as we speak
what kind of things do you think they
should be looking at I mean should
taxpayers money be on the table well I
think whatever happens the bank of
England is going to have to provide some
significant additional liquidity to
whoever buys
um svb and I think that's the most
likely outcome that it will be liquidity
means money cash money yeah because as I
understand it svb has good quality
assets it's not a question of the firm's
bust it's a question of it's unable to
turn those assets Into Cash quickly and
the bank of England can help there the
bank of England can step in and Loan it
money as it routinely does to Banks to
allow them to pay their depositors
um settle the nerves of the market and
then unwind its assets in a more orderly
fashion over a period of weeks or even
months uh thank you very much that's
interesting uh now we heard from the
chancellor earlier on the program
um there's a lot of jitteriness among
conservatives about the level of tax in
the UK cooperation tax obviously due to
rise by six percent and the chancellor
was pretty clear that he's going to
stick with that do you think that's the
right decision I think it's the right
decision for now
um I of course as I've said before lower
corporation tax is always better than
higher corporation tax for economic
growth
um but the thing that really matters to
businesses is the effective rate of
Taxation and I expect we're going to
hear the chancellor making some moves on
allowances and reliefs so that for many
businesses particularly those that are
investing heavily
um the effective rate of Corporation
taxes lowered a bit but I think what
business will be looking for is first of
all a signal from Jeremy Hunt that in
the medium to long term he does want to
see corporation tax lower that he
doesn't see 25 percent of some new
normal that's a tax for a moment in time
and secondly they're going to want to
see that apart from tax the government
recognizes and is tackling the
challenges of economic growth there are
many problems facing this economy at the
moment and if business sees the
government moving to deal with those
problems it'll be a little bit less
concerned about the higher rate of tax
how do you think they should be moving
to do it well I think there are three
big challenges for any conservative
Chancellor the first is he's got to
demonstrate fiscal responsibility and
especially given the circumstances in
which Rishi sunak came into office I
think they've done a great job in
stabilizing the markets stabilizing the
perception of the UK's public finances
but the job is absolutely not done and
we're still borrowing eye-wateringly
large amounts of money I've read in the
papers Jeremy Hunt might have 20 or 30
billion pounds of Headroom what that
Headroom really means is that he might
have he might be borrowing 20 30 billion
pounds less than we thought we would be
borrowing it's not real money we're
massively in the red so that job is not
finished and he's got to show an iron
resolution to complete that job secondly
he's got to continue the battle against
inflation because it's inflation that's
eroding people's living standards but
thirdly and I think this is where we're
going hopefully to see some strong
signaling
um in the budget
um he's got to set out a growth agenda
so that when we get through this period
of fiscal difficulty when we get out of
the period of high inflation we've at
least got something to look forward to
that the economy will return to growth
because the forecasts at the moment are
not very positive yes the UK economy
hasn't gone into a deep recession but it
is still way behind its peer group of
international economies do you think a
recession is likely
um if if there is it looks like it'll be
a shallow recession so we'll either
hover just above or just below the line
on recession but the real problem here
is looking out a year or two years what
we're not seeing is any signals that
will return to strong economic growth
and we need something a bit more than an
anemic sort of three-quarters of a
percent one percent one and a quarter
percent we need to find a way of getting
this economy back to growing at two
percent a year year in year out that's
the way we raise people's living
standards would Jeremy Hunt talked a lot
about getting people back into the
workplace which is pretty hard right if
you're left the workplace and you can
afford to do so it's quite difficult to
get those people back in I mean there is
an easy way to do this right to fill the
vacancies which would be to relax
certain immigration rules should they be
looking at that so the problems in our
economy are mainly on the supply side of
the economy it's not that there isn't
demand it's that there isn't there
aren't the resources to meet that demand
um there isn't the land with planning
permission to build the houses that
people want all the factories that
people want there aren't workers to fill
the jobs that are available so you're
absolutely right the the most obvious
way to deal particularly with the need
for lower skilled workers would be to
relax immigration rules but of course
um there is another political agenda out
there which is very concerned about
levels of immigration and this all gets
mixed up with the brexit debate and the
end of free movement to be honest do you
basically think that the most sensible
thing to do from a purely economic
perspectives is to relax immigration
rules but it's the politics that's
present preventing you from doing that
if I was a Chancellor and I was
unconstrained I would relax the
immigration rules in a very specific and
narrow way in that I would allow I would
issue a certain number of short-term
work visas for people who would come
here to do mainly lower skilled work
with no right to remain no rights of
settlement come stay three years work
and leave
um Jeremy Hunt won't do that because of
political constraints what he's going to
do I think and the signaling is pretty
clear is focus on trying to get people
who are already here into the workforce
so people who've retired early getting
them back in people who are thinking of
retiring early deterring them from doing
that people who are out because of
long-term health or mental health
problems helping them to get back into
the workforce and I think you'll see a
mixture of carrots and sticks some
generous child care support some
additional work training and support for
people who want to get back into the
workforce coupled with a slightly
tighter regime for benefits for people
who choose to stay out of the workforce
for long periods I just want to zoom out
for a minute
um the conservative party's polling is
abysmal right um
yeah that's one way of putting it
um what do you think the conservative
party needs to do if you're going to
have any chance of winning the next
election it feels to me like you're
focusing an awful lot on red wall seats
and perhaps not on the blue wall seats
like the ones that you used to represent
yeah well I think
um to be honest Rishi sunax doing it
what needs to be done the only thing he
can do after a period of extreme
turbulence is uh demonstrate again to
people that conservative governments
deliver fiscal stability get inflation
down and promote sound money and can
deliver a growth agenda for the medium
term that's the bit that's missing at
the moment and the thing that I really
want to see on Wednesday is a narrative
that shows that you know problems with
back bench Tory groups who
um don't like house building for example
or who don't want closer relations with
major trading partners like Europe or
who don't want to see relaxation of
migration rules can be overcome the Tory
party must go into the next election as
the party of fiscal responsibility and
economic growth it can't win an election
unless it is the champion of those two
principles you're talking about the need
for close Links of trading partners
another of those trading partners is
China I was quite interested in the
speech you made in February where you
talked about the trading relationship
and you said this you said for all the
noises we hear many of our Global
Partners have been partly increasing
their share of trade with China well we
have seen our stagnate over the pandemic
period time now to roll the sleeves up
get that market share climbing so you
think we should be doing more trade with
China yes I do I think um and we have to
be clear-eyed about China this has
always been my view on China China has a
very different political system very
different culture very different history
from us and we disagree profoundly with
them on some important issues but we
disagree profoundly with a lot of people
on important issues and we still trade
with them China is our fourth biggest
trading partner our sixth biggest export
Market we Proclaim that the UK is a
great global trading Nation we cannot
simply turn our back on the world's
second largest economy and our fourth
largest trading partner we have to
engage with them and we have to be clear
that simply because we're trading with
someone doesn't mean we endorse their
politics or their uh their political
culture in any way but we've got a long
tradition in the UK of trade-led
diplomacy and I think if we build our
trading links we then work on the other
issues that divide us I mean a lot of
your colleagues would just disagree with
that and not least because of Human
Rights abuses that we've seen in Hong
Kong the treatment of the uyghurs
reports the Sunday Times today that the
UK wants to see Tick-Tock banned from
all UK government electronic devices
well that's a secret that's a specific
security issue and we need to look at
that so that's on its on its merits but
we trade with lots of people
where we with whom we have human rights
concerns we have to be pragmatic about
the fact that we're talking about the
world's second largest economy here and
somehow I think some of my colleagues
have got a mindset that when we trade
with somebody we're doing them a favor
believe me it doesn't work like that we
need to trade we are a trading Nation
after brexit after covid after the
energy price crisis we have a challenge
in this country about how to deliver
growth how to earn our living so that we
can maintain our Public Services we can
improve people's standards of living in
the future and trade has to be a part of
that it's not a choice for us we've got
to get on and trade with the world now
before that you go I want to get your
take on the garyland Corral I quite like
questions where I don't actually know
what the answer is going to be and with
you and Gary lineke and the BBC I feel
like I genuinely don't know what your
view is on this which is always quite a
good position to start off with
what is your view is the entitled to
express its beliefs or does it go
against the impartiality of the BBC so I
think there's two things and I'm not an
expert in this area yeah there's two
things
um struck me reading this debate there's
we're in danger of confusing two
separate issues
um there's the impartiality of the BBC
which is a very important principle of
course for a public service broadcaster
and and it's I think probably by and
large the BBC usually gets it mostly
right because and I know that because
people in my party feel that the BBC is
institutionally biased against it and I
know that people in the labor party
equally feel that the BBC is
institutionally biased against it so
it's probably doing something
um about right then there's a separate
issue about whether individuals who are
closely associated with large
corporations can publicly Express views
which are highly controversial and are
not the views of that Corporation and I
think generally speaking that is not
acceptable it's even more important when
the corporation is a public body like
the BBC or indeed the Civil Service the
same would be true of a senior civil
servant tweeting out
um something that was highly
controversial but look it goes further
than that if a senior executive of Sky
were to tweet something highly
controversial they'd have a problem with
their management if a senior executive
of one of Britain's major but it's also
slightly it's different as well because
the license fee money as well right yeah
of course there's the public element but
if you talk to senior Executives or
senior figures across
high-profile businesses in the UK I
think you'll find them all saying that
they are extremely cautious about
publicly expressing views unless that
are controversial unless they are
clearly the views of the corporation
they work for very finely is there a
risk that BBC looks too close to the
government right now that they've
stepped in double footed if you're like
a double footed tackle on Gary lineker
we have The Rao over Richard Sharp not
disclosing his emboldment in
facilitating a loan to Boris Johnson is
it swinging too much well this is the
point isn't it it no doubt there will be
many people on the left of politics
saying look at this this is another
example of the BBC cozying up to the
Tory party I can tell you that the vast
majority of my former colleagues in the
Parliamentary Tory party see the BBC in
a different light is a champion it feels
like the scrutiny is on their closeness
to the concert party and it's right that
there should be um scrutiny on it okay
thank you very much indeed thank you